it was a good year for finding stuff out
I think of science kind of like a
whodunit only the answer to the question
is the universe our favorite sign
stories in 2015 I'll reveal some hidden
secret about the world around us let's
start with the western drought it
basically stopped raining like at all we
use that as a way to not just talk about
water policy but also hunt for solutions
not just a conservation but also for
climate change in general because even
El Nino driven rains aren't going to
solve this problem next up crisper the
technique for editing genomes as easily
as you would edit a document in a word
processor on the one hand screw those
malaria-carrying mosquitoes but what
about curing diseases in people well
maybe but what about engineering changes
in human beings that aren't cures for
diseases well that one's a little bit
more problematic and it's those kind of
ethical challenges that make this
science story even more interesting a
little less controversial what's so
important bacon the World Health
Organization added delicious delicious
bacon and other processed cook needs to
the list of things that might maybe
almost kind of sort of give you a little
more cancer than you otherwise might
maybe have gone unlike bacon this isn't
cut and dried you want to avoid cancer
don't smoke little bacon you're probably
okay now that seems to down earth for
you have some Pluto let me be very clear
human beings built a robot that flew 4.6
billion miles to the edge of the solar
system and took amazing pictures that
change the way people think about that
little dwarf planet oh and NASA handled
the social media around the event with
the mastery and aplomb of a 15 year old
Instagram star finally some
investigative work we did we looked at
the numbers of parents vaccinating their
kids in the schools and daycare centers
affiliated with the genius companies in
Silicon Valley that we cover
and it turned out the numbers were
pretty bad that is no good listen guys
you want to disrupt something get your
kids back side